thank you for talking to me about the
show i loved the season but i am also so
sad it's the last season
and i'm really curious for you guys when
and how did you find out season four
would be the final season does that kind
of news come in a phone call and email
the text like how does that work when
they tell you that news
i don't remember that
yes i don't remember them saying like
hey we got picked up but also it's the
last i don't remember like that moment
it's also been a very wild
14 months of life you know yeah so um
but i you know i think i think in the
general like we kind of all knew that we
were doing you know we wanted to go out
on a high note no pun intended
and uh and and do the best we could and
feel good about it and we'd be sad when
it was over but you know we care and
keep on keeping on
what are your feelings about the show
ending is it something that like do you
know how you feel about it being done is
it something that comes on gradually
like how do you deal with saying goodbye
to it after four seasons
i just feel
grateful honestly i mean
we
not all shows make it to four seasons or
not all shows get to know when they're
going to close their chapter um
not every show got to film
and get
filmed during the pandemic um you know i
and
i feel grateful that we got to do that
i
i also love that this show showcased
such
uh incredible talent like we got to we
got to all sing and dance in season four
like where they do that like that's
crazy um
yeah that's how i feel
what are you doing
it's like dealing with a breakup kind of
it's at that point where like you kind
of know
time to walk away
but like you don't want to
well how did you feel about the musical
aspect did you
like when you were told that was it
great was it oh my god i actually have
to do that like what was the reaction to
actually doing a musical
i mean i was kind of for it
i i said to justin like we've never gone
like full fellini before and he was like
yeah you're right so we're gonna do a
musical and i was like i'm in let's do
it
i just felt like you know all all we can
do is embrace
you know
uh
the process and everything and we were
shooting through a pandemic so we only
had a way to like embrace that through
like our own processes and doing uh that
music is very much my wheelhouse
logan's very very talented
and to be able to share those things
that we don't we never got to share like
previously in the show like it was kind
of like just an opportunity for like
logan and i to like record music and
break down a song and see what that was
going to be like you know
like we made the song that we do edited
very deep and it's not that deep of a
song
but we may
see she's still convinced i'm not
convinced that it's that deep but during
the moment she had me believing that
like we were doing some sort of like
something that was so huge and i was
like you're absolutely right and we were
in it together so
you know i'm grateful that we had that
experience that we got to have uh have
that to share i mean
there's only such a rarity to be able to
use every kind of aspect of your
performance to body voice mind sound
everything
so i tried to embrace it as soon as
possible
yeah i mean i have to say it that
duet for bye bye bye was like the most
emotional thing i've seen and i had no
idea like that song could do that to me
so
i mean were there conversations about
we're just going to make this as
emotional as possible
well that was kind of the tricky part
was we
we recorded the song before we shot the
scene
so we
as actors really had to go into the
booth and make a choice because it was
just us together um with our sound
engineer and
um
we had to decide you know
this is where they're coming off of this
is the scene before this is their
relationship this is what's happening in
the scene and where we want to leave
them
is this sad is this angry is this
confrontational
we did all that in the booth like we had
to make that choice because imagine like
if we made made it this like
angry in parts it should be melancholy
it just it wouldn't work so we had to be
on the same page
in the booth yeah we really dissected
the scene like i think our recording
session started but like let's just say
it started at two and we didn't go into
like 225 because logan and i are very
similar but we were like we were very
adamant about
going through like their relationship
past and what was the argument preceding
that song in general to know
what hurts what am i saying here
breaking it down like an actual scene oh
it was almost like our version uh season
four of like our version of like season
two episode eight of like what are we
really saying to each other so when we
get into the booth and sing and then we
can still play and say like hey i'm
going to do a little bit like this which
makes me kind of go like oh well then i
want to be down here to do that i mean
uh
it was it was pretty in intense but it
was great
there were points throughout the season
that made me emotional but especially
the
last episode really dead and i'm curious
with you guys i mean when you read the
last script did you get emotional
reading it did you get more emotional
filming the final scene like how
how did you feel about
reading that last script and actually
shooting that last moment
i was more emotional shooting it than
reading it because we were doing it over
zoom
so
the impact that we i usually have from
the table reads
you know are i get to be around
everybody and i felt like that would
have been a completely different a
different kind of catharsis
but filming filming those last moments
was probably
uh
one of the most surreal moments that
i've had as a performer let alone just
like as a person just kind of like
everyone together the silence just all
you like you could feel the heartbeats
in the room and
that was
that was intense
uh you know and i wasn't surprised that
we were emotional about it
i i knew that something was going to
happen
however it happened and
we had to suck it up and wipe the face
and take two or take three or take four
to get it
but uh
yeah you know what you've met so much
you know what made me the most emotional
about filming that last thing that that
like pushed that pull out it was like a
long long this long lens like going past
everyone's face
all i kept thinking of was
i kept thinking of everyone who ever saw
themselves in my character and i was
just like this is what i'm leaving them
with i'm leaving them with themselves
i'm leaving them with themselves at this
moment and i felt like i was looking
into their eyes and being and and
it was such a
strange surreal
emotion it was emotional like
because there are people we've connected
with we've never met
that's that's bonkers logan also we were
shooting it and we didn't like rehearse
it so much as like the camera move and
the first time we shot it all of a
sudden the lights the practical lights
oh yeah down and everyone was like what
whoa
we were already like kind of sad and
then all of a sudden the lights go out
into the dark and you can just feel like
the hairs on everyone's
like necks look like they're looking i'm
feeling it too it's just it was it was
i'll never forget that moment the first
time the lights closed and i was like oh
my god like that's it and then when i
had to like become a person again and
then
but yeah that was that was yeah it was
emotional it was sad
i thought i'm really so happy we get to
have those moments like that's that's so
beautiful to be able to like a bunch of
people coming together and feeling
things
you know just
beautiful we're so lucky
i thought it was a really beautiful
moment and the series on i
would not have expected that it ended
that way and i just think it was really
perfect and beautiful and that doesn't
happen often so
thank you thank you guys for talking to
me about it